these tents have collapsed under the
weight of snow
people are scrambling to clear it
before their homes here in
camp also cave in
in the beginning we were able to control
the situation since we're used to living
in the tents but in the end the tents
couldn't handle the snow anymore the
snowfall increased and increased
it got so much that some tents caved in
and it was a tragedy for the people
living under them
the storm called hibba began on tuesday
night and hit countries across the
middle east
but it's displaced syrians who are
feeling the brunt of it
we've been here for two and a half years
and last night was the most difficult
night the tents fell down on us and we
suffered a lot we helped each other and
we woke up to clear the tents from snow
aid agencies have said families could
freeze to death as temperatures are
expected to drop to the lowest in 40
years and wind speeds are predicted to
reach 80 kilometers per hour
agencies are trying to clear the snow
but families will struggle to stay warm
and here in the syrian countryside
they're trying to do what they can just
to survive this latest storm
assalbaig al-jazeera